- 11 jours après les inondations
dévastatrices dans l'est
du Kentucky, Joe Biden s'est
rendu sur place pour constater
l'ampleur des dég. . . Au moins
37 personnes y ont perdu la vie.
Pas le moment, donc, de célébrer
la victoire demomomocrates
au Sénat dimanche. Les désastres
naturels se multiplient aux
États-Unis. Un rappel quotidien
de l'urgence climatiqu
"On n'abandonne jamais dit-il,
on ne s'incline pas,
on va de l'avant".
Et le Sénat est allé de l'avant
la veille.
(applaudissements)
... En votant pour le projet de
loi de plus de 700 milliards de
dollars, sur la réduction de
l'inflation avec une importante
enveloppe budgétaire
de 369 milliards de dollars pour
le climat. C'est le plus gros
vevevestissement en environnemet
jamais effectué aux États-Unis.
L'objectif : réduire lesémémémit
de serre de 40 % d'ici 2030.
Le gouvernement encourage
l't t t de voitures électriques
en offrant un crédit d'impôt
qui ira jusqu'à 7500 $.
Et pour les panneaux solaires,
30 % de l'installation
sera prise en charge.
"Ça a été une longue douloureuse
route dit-il, mais nous y sommes
arrivés".
Car ça aura pris 18 longs mois,
un véritable marathon pour
allier tous les sénateurs
démocrates. En santé, plus
de 60 milliards de dollars sont
prévus. On parle de médicaments
moins chers, car le Medicare
pourra renégocier les prix.
Également, les personnes âgées,
vulnérables ne payeront pas plus
que 2000 $ par année pour leurs
médicaments. Le gouvernement
Biden compte aussi récolter des
sous. Désormais, les compagnies
qui font des profits de plus
de 1 milliard de dollars devront
payer 15 % en impôt minimal.
Ce qui pourrait générer plus
de 250 milliards de dollars,
une mesure qui hér
les républicains.
"Embaucher 85 000 agents
du revenu supplémentaire, lance
le sénateur républicain
Lindsey Graham, ne vous leurrez
pas dit-il, ils vont aller
chercher les serveuses, les
chauffeurs d'Uber pour récolter
le plus d'impôt possible".LaLaLa
voter sur ce projet de loi avant
que le président ne signe le
texte pour qu'il devienne loi.
Les démocrates espèrent que
cette victoire va leur donner
un nouveau souffle à 92 jours
des élections de mi-mandat.
A A Azeb Wolde-Giorghis
Radio-Canada, Washingto